اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في اخبار الساعه من
العربيه نستعرض ونرصد معكم ابرز المستجدات
وفي العناوين
الجيش الاوكراني يعلن عن هجوم الروسي
لاستهدف مدينه دينبرو بسته عشر صاروخا
وعشرين مسيره
وزراء خارجيه دول الاتحاد الاوروبي
يجتمعون في بروكسل وحزمه عقوبات جديده
مرتقبه ضد روسيا
قوات اسرائيليه تقتحم مخيم بلاطه
بالجرافات وتقتل ثلاثه
الليبيون يجتمعون في مدينه بوزنيقه
المغربيه للتوافق على قانون الانتخابات
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا اكد الجيش الاوكراني ان
روسيا هاجمت مدينه دينيبرو خلال الليل
بسته عشر صاروخا وعشرين طائره مسيره وسمع
دوي انفجارات ايضا في مدينتي خار كيف
وزافوريجيا وافادت وسائل الاعلام بوقوع 15
انفجارا في مدينه دينيبرو خلال اكثر من 90
دقيقه من الانذارات واشاد حاكم منطقه
دينيبرو بتروفيسك بقوات الدفاع الاوكرانيه
وصمودها امام الهجوم
في المقابل المشاهدين اعلن مسؤولون موادنا
لروسيا في زابوريا بجنوب اوكرانيا رفع
حاله الطوارئ في المحطه النوويه بسبب
انقطاع الكهربائي واكدوا ان محطه بوريج
نوويه باتت مفصوله تماما عن مصادر الطاقه
الخارجيه وتعتمد حاليا على مولدات داخليه
احتياطيه ومن جهتها اكدت شركه الطاقه
الاوكرانيه انقطاع التيار الكهربائي عن
المحطه النوويه من جانبها مشاهدينا قالت
الدفاع البريطانيه ان روسيا بدات تشكيل
قوات نخبه جويه هجوميه لدعم المعارك على
الارض في اوكرانيا وافادت في احدث تقييم
استخباراتي بان هذه القوات تدعى ستورم
ومدعومه مدعومه بمقاتلات زوخوي 24
وسوخي 34 ومروحيات هجوميه قتاليه وشارت
الدفاع البريطانيه ايضا مشاهدينا
الى ان روسيا تستقطب طيارين عسكريين ذوي
خبرات كبيره لضمهم لفرقه النخبه الجديده
مشاهدينا معنا مراسل العربيه رائد الاغبر
اهلا بك رائد وبدايه ما مدى خطوره الوضع
في زبوريجه بعد الاعلان عن انقطاع التيار
الكهربائي في محطتها النوويه
صباح الخير احمد بالفعل المعارك منتشره
وممتده في المحورين الجنوبي والشرقي من
اوكرانيا والقصف الروسي شامله عده مقاطعات
قالت المصادر العسكريه الروسيه انها قصفت
دينيبرو بتروس وايضا كما انها قصفت اديسا
وخاركب تقول بانها تقصف الامدادات
العسكريه الغربيه التي تصل حيث مستودعات
الذخيره والقواعد العسكريه الاوكرانيه
وهناك قصف متبادل ما بين القوات
الاوكرانيه والقوات الروسيه ما اسفر عن
قصف الجيش الاوكراني لمدينه حيث المحطه
النوويه في زبروجي كما ان القصف يشمل
مدينه خرسون او مقاطعه خرسون حيث المناطق
التي تسيطر عليها روسيا هذا القصف كما
اسلفت اسفر عن انقطاع التيار الكهربائي
نتيجه استهداف محطات الطاقه وانتاج
هذه ليست المره الاولى التي تتعرض فيها
المحطه النوويه ومحيطه الى القصف هناك
ايقاف مؤقت
للمنشات النوويه
وامدادات كهربائيه يعني من غير المحطه
الخاصه بانتاج الطاقه ننتظر الساعات
القادمه حتى نعرف مدى خطوره هذا الامر حيث
المحطه النوويه لكن لابد من ان نسلط الضوء
على ما يحدث في مدينه باخمت والتطورات بعد
سيطره قوات فاجنر على هذه المدينه قال
القائم باعمال المقاطعه هنا فينيس بوشيليم
بان عمليات تنظيف مستمره التنظيف من
الالغام ومن مخلفات الحرب وذلك من اجل
افساح الطريق للمؤسسات الحكوميه والمؤسسات
المدنيه لبدء عملها بانشاء يعني الشبكات
شبكات التواصل
واعاده بناء يعني البنى المدينه على غرار
ما حصل في مدينه ماريوبل سابقا كما ان
قائد قوات فاغنار
اكد بان مهمته هي السيطره على مدينه باخمت
وهو اتم هذه المهمه وسينسحب بالفعل في
الخامس والعشرين من هذا الشهر ولن يحارب
ولن يقاتل في اي محور اخر مسلطا الضوء على
المعارك في جنوب مدينه
التسليم والتسلم بين فاقنر والقوات او
الجيش الروسي يوم الخميس المقبل 60 بسالام
ان هناك بعض التعقيدات ربما
انا يعني من مصادرنا العسكريه احمد اؤكد
لك بان القوات الروسيه حاضر على الارض في
باخمت تقاتل في محوري ايفانا
المحور الجنوبي الذي يشهد حشودات عسكريه
اوكرانيه كبيره شنت هجمات من اجل العوده
واعاده السيطره على باقي صدتها القوات
الروسيه المدفعيه الروسيه سلاح الجو
الروسي يعمل في ذلك المحور القوات الروسيه
حاضره وهي تقاتل قوات فاجنر اكملت مهمتها
ولا تقاتل الان في مدينه باخموت هي تستعد
للانسحاب من يعمل الارض على الارض الان في
مدينه باقمت هو الجيش الروسي وحده لا غير
لكن هناك ايضا تطورات في محاور ابديفكا
ومارنكا حيث ان هناك امدادات عسكريه كبيره
حسب القائم باعمال الرئاسه هنا دينيس
بوشليم في الدبكه هناك امدادات عسكريه
بشريه وبالمعدات في مدينه
المتاخمه لباخم طبعا والقريبه جدا هو هذا
كله المحور الشمالي الغربي حيث مارينكا
باخموت
هناك امدادات عسكريه كبيره وهناك احتمال
لشن هجمات اوكرانيه مضاده ضد الجيش الروسي
تقول المصادر المحليه بان الجيش الروسي
مستعد وعد يعني خطط دفاعيه وتحصينات لمنع
اي هجوم اوكراني يمكن ان يحصل في الايام
القادمه بشكل عام المعارك مستعره على جميع
المحاور ان كانت الجنوبيه او الشرقيه هناك
تقدم بطيء للقوات الروسيه في محور مارينكا
واتمام للسيطره على باقي وعمليات يعني
تنظيف كما يصفها هنا يعني السلطات المحليه
شكرا لك كنت معنا رائدا اغبر تحيه رائد
مشاهدينا معنا الصحفي محمد البابا اهلا بك
محمد وكيف يتفاعل بدايه امر هذا الهجوم
الروسي على كل من نادي نيبرو وخاركيف
وايضا زابوريجيا ما الذي رصد ايضا من
تصريحات ومواقف
يعني حتى هذه اللحظه وزاره الدفاع
الاوكرانيه اعلنت عن اسباب عشرين صاروخ 13
صاروخ وعشرين مسيره اطلقوا باتجاه مدينه
الدفر هارك التي تعرضت ايضا لاطلاق صواريخ
اس ثلاثه مئه لسفر روسيا ايضا تم
استهدافها بمثيرات وبصواريخ ارسل استثناء
يعني قبل حوالي دقيقه عشر دقائق كنا في
اتصال مع وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه التي
تتكلم عن هذا التصعيد الكبير منذ بدايه
شهر ماي حتى اليوم يعني الجيش الروسي كشف
عمليات استهداف المدن الاوكرانيه
بالصواريخ
يعني المسيرات الانتحاريه منذ بدايه حتى
اليوم هناك ثلاثه عشر هجوم او 14 هجوم
بالصواريخ والمسيرات اي ما يعني كل يوم او
يومين هناك هجوم اما على العاصمه
الاوكرانيه كيف او على المدن مثل
وايضا يعني تم استهداف منشات عسكريه
ومنشات مدنيه في مدينه نيكل هناك معلومات
عن سقوط اصابات من المدنيين لكن الجيش
الاوكراني الان يعني يتداول والحديث
الاساسي في الجيش الاوكراني هو ما يحصل في
محيط مدينه عن تقدم القوات الاوكرانيه في
محيط مدينه باخموت ويكتشر الجيش الاوكراني
الان لحصار تلك المدينه من الجهه الغربيه
والجهه الشماليه والجنوبيه استعدادا لقيام
القوات الاوكرانيه بالدخول واقتحام
والتقدم داخل هذه المدينه بعد ارسال
تعزيزات عسكريه دبابات واليات شهدت من
مدينه خالقه من مدينه
تتجه الى تلك المنطقه منطقه العمليات في
قطاع الدنبره محمد ان اولويه القوات
الاوكرانيه الان هو هي استعاده باخموت
وليست تركيز او تركيز الجهود على للدفاع
او السيطره على مناطق اخرى
كان هناك قرار صدر من وزاره الدفاع
الاوكرانيه ويتم
بشكل وايضا حمايه مريمكا لان الجيش الروسي
بدا يكيف يكثف عمليته خاصه فيماك التي
ايضا اصبحت مدمره بشكل كامل مثلها على
غرار ما حصل في فخمه معظم المباني السكنيه
يعني تعرضت لضربات وتدمير اما جزئي واما
كلي في تلك المدينه تم اجلاء المدنيين
بشكل كبير والان تعمل ايضا فرق الاسعافات
وفرق التابعه لوزاره اعاده الدمج على
اجلاء المدنيين من منطقه ومحيطها خوفا من
قيام الروسيه او خوفا من نقل مجموعات
يعني لاستكمال ما يحصل في تلك المناطق من
تقدم للقوات الروسيه يستعد خلال يعني ايام
قليله او ساعات قليله سيبدا بهجوم وعمليه
خاصه في مدينه شكرا لك محمد البابا تحياتي
محمد
سياسيه مشاهدينا حضر سفير روسيا لدى
الولايات المتحده انطونوف واشنطن من خطوره
حصول اوكرانيا على مقاتله اف 16 ومن ان
استخدامها في الهجمات على شبه جزيره القرم
سيعد اعتداء على روسيا الولايات المتحده
ان تكون على درايه كامله بالرد الروسي على
اي هجوم اوكراني محتمل كما قال السفير
الروسي ان ارسال مقاتله اف 16 الى
اوكرانيا سيثير تساؤلات ايضا حول ضلوع
الحلف جمعيه الاطلسي في الصراع
بينما تخسر اوكرانيا معركه في حربها مع
روسيا على الجبهه الاخرى تستعد لمعارك
اعتى فانضمام طائرات اف 16 الى سلاح الجو
الاوكراني كبديل عن طائرات صوفياتيه اكل
الدهر عليها وشرب هي نقطه تحول اخرى في
مسار الحرب الاوكرانيه
لطالما رفضت واشنطن تقديم مقاتلات شرسه
الى اوكرانيا خوفا من التصعيد مع روسيا او
حتى خوفا من تسريب التكنولوجيا التي تعمل
بها الى موسكو وفق السي انا
معتبره ان حاجه كييف تقتصر على حمايه
البنيه التحتيه وصد الهجمات الروسيه لكن
الضغوط من قبل البنتاجون والكونغرس
الامريكي على مدى اشهر على الاداره
الامريكيه غيرت الدفه بالاتجاه المعاكس
قرار يجسد النظره الامريكيه المتغيره تجاه
الوضع الاوكراني فبينما تنفذ صواريخ كييف
تزداد الحاجه لحمايه الاجواء الاوكرانيه
لكن الامداد بمقاتلات من نوع اف 16 يدل
على تصور واشنطن لمستقبل الحرب
واستمراريتها ربما لسنوات في اوكرانيا حتى
مع التوجه الى حل التفاوض
بالاضافه للتشكيك بالهجوم المضاد الذي
تستعد له
تفوق جوي سيفرض القوه والغلبه لصاحبه
تحاول اوكرانيا الوصول اليه واختصرته على
لسان وزير الخارجيه الاوكراني
ديميتروكوليبا في خمس نقاط الحاجه لتطوير
سلاح الجو الاوكراني لصد الغارات الروسيه
التي لا تستطيع انظمه الدفاع الجوي ردعها
دعم القوات البريه والتقليل من خسائرها
على الارض بتوفير الحمايه الجويه لهم
حمايه صادرات الحبوب عبر البحر الاسود من
خلال تامين خط تصدير
مواجهه مباشره بين السلاحين الامريكي
والروسي لاختبار القدرات
الحفاظ على الحدود الاوروبيه من ترسيم
روسي قد يغير جغرافيه القاره حرب تحولت من
نزاع على الحدود الجغرافيه الى حرب
استنزاف بين الطرفين الفائز فيها هو الطرف
الذي يستمر في التزويد اللوجستي لاطول
فتره ممكنه
مدينه هيروشيما اليابانيه الرئيس
الاوكرانيزيا بمدينه
الصحفيين اثناء حضوره قمه مجموعه السابع
لم يكن يقصد به الاساءه الى رئيس الامريكي
جو بايدن الحليف الاول له بالطبع لكنه اكد
ان صوره
يذكره تذكره وتجمعات السكنيه المماثله
ايضا المنهاره مبانيها تصريح لم يمر مرور
الكرام حيث التقطته سريعا المتحدثه الرسمي
باسم الخارجيه الروسيه ماريا التي ردت على
الرئيس الاوكراني بقولها لا تنسى ان البيت
الابيض رتب الامرين في اشاره منها الى ان
امريكا وراء تذكيه الصراع الروسي
الاوكراني الذي تجلى باعنف صوره وايضا
مدينتيه هيروشيما ونجازاكي اللتين قصفتها
بالنووي الامريكي في نهايه الحرب العالميه
الثانيه في العام
1945 نتابع
شو استطيع القول بصراحه ان صور هيروشيما
المدمره تذكرني بباخمت وغيرها من المدن
المماثله لا يوجد شيء على الاطلاق تم
تدمير جميع المباني لا يمكن حتى ادراك
اماكن الشوارع والمباني هذا دمار كامل
مطلق لا يوجد شيء ولا يوجد بشر
افادم راس العربي بانه من المقرر ان يجتمع
اليوم وزراء خارجي في دول الاتحاد
الاوروبي في بروكسيل حيث سيناقش وزراء
الخارجيه ملفات منها مواصله الدعم العسكري
ومحاسبه المسؤولين عن الحرب في اوكرانيا
فضلا عن مواصله بحث حزمه العقوبات الحاديه
عشره روسيا وضد كيانات تابعه للدول الاخرى
التي تنتهك انظمه العقوبات ضد روسيا ايضا
هذا وسيعمل مسؤول ملف العقوبات ديفيد على
تقديم تقرير الى الوزراء حول نتائج
الاتصالات التي اجراها مع الدول التي
يشتبه في ان بعض هيئتها اعاده تصدير
العتاد الاوروبي الى روسيا
هذا واستبعد مفوض الشؤون الخارجيه
بالاتحاد الاوروبي جزيره بوي الفك
الارتباط مع الصين مؤكدا ان لا احد في
اوروبا يفكر في ذلك وقال بوارير قبل بدء
اجتماع وزراء خارجيه الاتحاد من المناقشات
تدور حول خفض الاعتماد على الصين حيث وصلت
قيمه التبادلات التجاريه مليارين و700
مليون يورو يوميا من جهه اخرى اكد بوري
على الاجتماع سيشرع على الفور في مناقشه
العقوبات المحدده من مجموعه السبع وخاصه
المتعلقه بروسيا وقال ايضا ان عمليات
تدريب الطبيعيه الاوكرانيين على مقاتلات
اف 16 بدات وان الباب اصبح مفتوحا
لارسالها الى كييف
مشاهدينا العربي نورديال اهلا بك نور
الدين والاهميه التي يكتسبها هذا الاجتماع
اليوم من حيث التوقيت والدلاله ايضا
وزراء خارجيه الاتحاد الاوروبي تتركز بشكل
اساسي في ضوء ما حدث في الاسابيع الماضيه
من عمليه تحذير خاصه واجتماعات تحذيريه
لحزمه العقوبات وخاصه توصيات مجموعه الدول
الغنيه سبعه في نهايه الاسبوع في هيروشيما
في اليابان
المباحثات تتركز بشكل اساسي حول هذه
الحزمه الحاديه عشره والتي تتميز بشيئين
اساسيين او بفصلين اساسيين على الصعيد
الاوروبي ادماج قطاع الالماس لاول مره
بحيث يتم حظر استيراد الالماس الروسي الى
الى السوق الاوروبيه وهذه القضيه طرحت على
مدى اشهر ولكن الاوروبيون كانوا دائما
يرجعون هذا الموضوع لماذا لان مدينه
الواقعه في شمال بلجيكا والتي يسميها
اهلها بعاصمه الالماس
86% من تجاره الالماس تعبر باخرى مدينه
انتورب حيث عشرات الالاف يعملون في قطاع
الالماس وان اهل القطاع يقولون من ان حظر
استيراد الالماسي من روسيا سيجعل هذه
الكميات وروسيا اكبر ثاني اول منتج من حيث
الكميه للالماس سيتجه نحو الهند نحو
اسرائيل ونحو مدن متخصصه او ذات قطاعات
متقدمه في صناعه الالماسي والمجوهرات
القضيه مطروحه على مستوى وزراء الخارجيه
تاخذ بعض الوقت لان هناك بعض الحلول
التقنيه ربما ناتي اليها
في الوقت المناسب طيب نور الدين يعني هل
يتوقع ان تخرج هذه القيمه او هذا الاجتماع
بقرارات ملزمه بمجرد
اطر عامه حول هذه الملفات المطروحه على
طول النقاشات اليوم
فيما يتعلق بقضيه العقوبات هناك هذا
الجانب اللي هو جانب الالماس ولكن هناك
عدد كبير من الشركات هناك جانب اخر سيكون
ملزما واذا ردا على سؤال حضرتك القرارات
التي تكون هنا على مستوى الخارجيه هي
ملزمه للدول الاعضاء 27 هناك جانب يتعلق
استهدافي شركات الدول مثل تركيا او الصين
وبعض الدول التي شركاتها تستورد منتجات
اوروبيه ثم تعيد تصديرها تصدير هاته
المنتجات من كازاخستان على سبيل المثال
الى روسيا فهناك هذا يعني حمله من
الاتصالات اجراها
مع الدول المعنيه والهند بشكل اساسي اصبحت
في دعنا نقول تحت المجهر لان السوق
الاوروبيه تستوعب 60 مليون برميل في الشعر
من المشتقات النفطيه التي تصدر الهند بعد
ان تكون قد استوردت خامه روسيا هذه مشكله
كبيره وهناك ايضا عدد من الشركات الصينيه
ستدرج في قوائم العقوبات ولكن المساله
تاخذ بعض الوقت مع احمد شكرا لك من كنت
معنا مراسل العربيه نور الدين تحياتي نور
الدين
مستمرا المشاهدين او فيها بعض الفاصل
مقاتلات مقاتلات الجيش السوداني تقصف
مواقع للدعم السريع في الخرطوم قبيله بدء
تنفيذ الهدنه مساء اليوم
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد كشفت وزاره
الصحه الفلسطينيه ان القوات الاسرائيليه
قتلت ثلاثه
وكشف بيان نشرته وكاله الانباء الفلسطينيه
كشف ان القوات الاسرائيليه خلال اقتحامها
مخيم بلاطه قامت بنشر تعزيزات عسكريه
ومحاصره منازل للمواطنين
ان محادثه في مخيم بلاطه يعد مجزره حقيقيه
ويمثل استمرارا للحرب الشامله التي يتعرض
لها الشعب الفلسطيني على حد وصفها كما
حملت الرئاسه الفلسطينيه الحكومه
الاسرائيليه المسؤوليه عن التصعيد
والجرائم المستمره وسياسه العقاب الجماعي
[موسيقى]
يا عم الدار فاضي يا عمي ما في مدينه
الجنين بطفة الغربيه ايضا افاد مراسل
العربيه بانسحاب القوات الاسرائيليه
تدريجيا بعد اعتقالها مجموعه من الشبان
الفلسطينيين وذلك بعد اقتحام القوات
الاسرائيليه جنين واندلاع اشتباكات مسلحه
مع مجموعه من المقاتلين لتواصل بذلك
القوات الاسرائيليه عمليه اقتحام المدن في
الضفه الغربيه
[موسيقى]
مخيم بلاطه في نابلس ينضم الى مراسله
عربيه خالد القاسم اهلا بك خالد وكيف بدا
المشهد في مخيم بلاطه بعد انسحاب القوات
الاسرائيليه منه
نعم احمد يستعد للفلسطينيون في هذه
الاثناء لتشجيع ثلاثه قتلهم الجيش
الاسرائيلي فجر هذا اليوم في مخيم بلاطه
حيث اقتحم المخيم اكثر من 400 ضابط وجندي
اسرائيلي حاصروا المخيم من جميع مداخله ثم
تدخلت قوات خاصه الى داخل المخيم وقامت
بمحاصره احد المنازل تقول البيانات
العسكريه الاسرائيليه بانهم عثروا على
مخبر لتصنيع المتفجرات في هذا المنزل
صاحبه المنزل قالت بانهم فور وصولهم بداوا
باطلاق الرصاص لذلك لم نستطع من مغادره
المنزل وبعد انسحاب الجيش الاسرائيلي بعشر
دقائق انفجر المنزل اي السقوط لذلك طلب
منا من الطواقم الهندسيه التابعه للبلديه
ومن الهلال الاحمر والدفاع المدني بمغادره
المنطقه لان المنزل قد يسقط في ايه لحظه
العمليه ايضا اسفرت عن اصابه سبعه
فلسطينيين بالرصاص الحي اضافه الى اختناق
في 45 اخرين باستنشاق الغاز المسيل للدموع
عمليه اجتياح مخيم بلاطه استمرت من الساعه
الواحده حتى الساعه الخامسه فجرا بالتزامن
مع اجتياح مخيم جنين والذي اسفر عن اعتقال
عدد من الفلسطينيين سواء في مخيم بلاطه او
في مخيم الجنين لتكون حصيله الاعتقالات
لهذا اليوم 13 فلسطينيه طيب خلينا تابعنا
تصريحات من الرئاسه الفلسطينيه بما حدث في
مخيم بوناطه في جنين لكن على صعيد الشعبي
هل من حراكم معين او دعوات لحركه معين بعد
عمليه تشييع جثامين ضحايا هذا الهجوم
الاسرائيلي او الاقتحام
يعني مبدئيا القوى الوطنيه والاسلاميه
اعلنت الاضراب والحداد الشامل في محافظه
نابلس بعد مقتل الفلسطينيين الثلاث هناك
دعوات من عده
تنظيمات لتنظيم مسيرات مندده بهذه
العمليات العسكريه الاسرائيليه اضافه الى
التصريحات الرسميه التي اوردت بعضها احمد
في بدايه الخبر والتي تحمل اسرائيل
المسؤوليه عما يجري وتحملها ايضا مسؤوليه
تبعات هكذا عمليات مستمره سواء في منطقه
جنين او في منطقه نابلس وتحديدا في مخيمي
المدينتين مخيم جنين ومخيم بلاطه في حديثك
الى اصابه سته فلسطينيين خاصنا في مخيم
بلاطه هل توفت لك معلومات حول الحاله
الصحيه لهم
الاصابات
متوسطه الا اصابه واحده حرجه للغايه حتى
هذه اللحظه وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه تقول
بان هذه الاصابه ما تزال حرجه تجرى له
العمليات اللازمه وهو في العنايه المركزه
بقيه الاصابات وصفت بين المتوسطه الى
الخطيره حيث اصابه السبعه كانت بالرصاص
الحي خلال الاشتباكات شكرا لكم من مخيم
بلاطه في نابلس مثل العربيه خالد القاسم
تحيه خالد
قبيله دخول اتفاق وقف اطلاق النار الذي
وقعه الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع
في جده حيز التنفيذ مساء اليوم الاثنين
يعيش سكان العاصمه السودانيه حاله من
الترقب خصوصا في ظل سماع ذوي عده قذائف
ثقيله اطلقها الجيش نحو مراكز للدعم
السريعه في الخرطوم فجر اليوم حسب ما افاد
مراسل العربيه حيث اعرب عبد من السكان عن
امنهم بثبات الهدنه القصيره التي ستمتد
لسبعه ايام وفق الاتفاق جدا على ان تمدد
لاحقا باتفاق الطرفين يذكر مشاهدينا ان
هذا الاتفاق الاخير الذي وقع في جده ليس
الاول منذ بدء الحرب بين الجيش والدعم
السريع اذ اتفق الطرفان على ما يقرب من
اثنتي عشره هدنه خلقت كلها بعد دقائق على
دخولها حيز التنفيذ
بنعمل انه تكون الهدنه يعني
منتهيه الى حل ينهي المشاكل والصعاب والله
ما شايف لنا حلل يعني للهدنه يعني ويعني
بلدي
السرقه والاعدم الامان وعدم الغاز وعدم
العلاج وعدم كله هي الامر الوحيد في
الهدنه ان هبه هتحمي الناس هتحمي الناس
الاغتصاب وهتحمي الناس من الغطر وهتحمي
الناس من الجريمه الناس لعبه جات يعني
تعبت يعني
فالناس
من المعيشه
الخروج من هذه المشاكل يعني الليله اكثر
يوم يعني كويس
بس في طيارات لكن ما في ما في ما في ما
سمعنا صوت الرصاص يعني الهدنه ماشاء
يعني كويس يعني
عفوا وتعهد الطرفان ايضا بالانتناع عن
التحريض واستخدام اي مجموعات قبليه او
عرقيه في الصراع الدائر كما يمنع الاتفاق
تقييد او اعاقه حركه المدنيين بما فيهم
العاملون في المجال الانساني او استخدام
المدنيين كدروع بشريه نتابع
ناهد ثقيل
في تطورات المساعي الاجراء الانتخابات
الرئاسيه والبرلمانيه الليبيه اكد مصدر
الليبي من لجنه 6 + 6 وصول اعضاء اللجنتين
المشتركتين من مجلسي النواب والدوله
الليبيين الى منتجع بوزنيقه في ضواحي
العاصمه المغربيه الرباط حيث سيكون
الاجتماع النبي برعايه مغربيه
وبحضور خبراء اماميين لدعم اللجنه في
المسائل الدستوريه والانتخابيه كذلك كما
تواجه الجوله الجديده من المفاوضات
الليبيه الليبيه تحدي الوصول الى صيغه
توافقيه لترشح العسكريين وايضا لترشح
حامله جنسيتين اي ثنائي الجنسيه من
الليبيين
مشاهدينا من الرباط معنا مراسله العربيه
عادل الزبيري اهلا بك عادل اذا متى ستنعقد
اعمال هذا اجتماع الليبي الليبي وما الذي
يواجه يواجه نجاحه من تحديات وصعوبات
مرحبا تنطلق اليوم في منتجع بوزنيقه في
دواح العاصمه المغربيه الرباط جوله
مفاوضات سياسيه ليبيه الليبيه ولكن هذه
المره من اجل التوصل الى صياغه التوافقات
او اتفاقات الليبيه الليبيه تتعلق بملف
ليبي انشائك الا وهو الانتخابات الرئاسيه
والبرلمانيه من خلال حزمه قوانين جديده
باستضافه مغربيه ورعايه من الامم المتحده
ابرز الخلافات مجلس النواب الليبي يدعو
ويطالب بضروره مشاركه جميع الاسماء
الليبيه القديمه والجديده اي فتح الباب
امام ترشح الجميع فيما المجلس الاعلى
للدوله الليبيه لديه تحفظ على ما يسميها
بالشخصيات العسكريه وايضا لديه تحفظ على
شخصيات يقول انها تنتمي الى ما يسمى
بالنظام الليبي القديم كذلك هنالك نصوص
بحسب مصادر العربيه سيجري اقت من الطرفين
او صياغات قانونيه تدقيقا من اجل الخروج
من عنق الزجاجه في هذا الملف الليبي الشاي
لكن يبدو ان الطرفين الليبيين يحملان
معهما من جديد بحسب مصادر العربيه
خلافاتهما القديمه بحيث ان هذه الجوله رغم
ان الليبيين والمراقبين يعولون عليها
كثيرا من اجل الوصول الى قاعده دستوريه
وقوانين تنظم انتخابات برلمانيه ورئاسيه
طال انتظارها بحسب المراقبين في ليبيا
وايضا في المنطقه المغاربيه الا ان هذه
الخلافات الداخليه تزال قائمه خصوصا مساله
الحسم مثلا في امكانيه فتح المجال يترشح
اسماء من قبيل ابن العقيد الليبي معمر
القذافي سيف الاسلام القذافي والذي يعارض
من طرف احد الطرفي الازمه السياسيه
الليبيه هنالك محاولات تجري في الكواليس
منذ البارحه في منتجع بوزنيقه للدخول في
هذه بروح ايجابيه من اجل التوصل الى
اتفاقات سريعه تمكن هذه الازمه الرئاسيه
على مستوى الانتخابات وايضا البرلمانيه من
الخروج من هذا الجمود هنالك حديث عن
امكانيه ان تكون هذه المفاوضات السياسيه
الليبيه الليبيه مغلقه اي بعيدا عن
الانظار في انتظار ما سيفرز عنه هذا اليوم
الاول نعم ونحن في متابعه لمجرات هذا
الاجتماع شكرا
مشاهدينا قالت وكاله التسليم للانباء
الايرانيه شبه الرسميه ان الرئيس الايراني
ابراهيم رئيس
الامن القومي خلفا لعلي الشمخاني وشغل
احمد احمد مياه ان سابقا منصب رئيس
الاركان المشترك للحرس الثوري ودول رئاسه
المركز الاستراتيجي الحرس منذ عام 2006
نشاه ترى مستمره اذا وفيها بعد الفاصل
رايدها الفضاء السعوديه علي غارني علي
القرني وريان برماوي باول رحله من نوعها
الى الفضاء
الجيش الاوكراني يعلن عن هجوم الروسي
استهدف مدينه سته عشر صاروخا وعشرين مسيره
خارجيه دول الاتحاد الاوروبي يجتمعون في
بروكسل وحزمه عقوبات جديده مرتقبه ضد
روسيا
قوات اسرائيليه تقتحم مخيم بلاطه
بالجرافات وتقتل ثلاثه فلسطينيين والسلطه
تصفها بالمجزره
الفرقاء الليبيون يجتمعون في مدينه
بوزنيقه المغربيه للتوافق على قانون
الانتخابات
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد اعلنت وكاله
ناسا الفضائيه انطلاق المركبه دراغون من
مركز كندي الفضائي في فلوريدا بمهمه
فضائيه الى محطه الفضاء الدوليه وعلى
متنها اعضاء
الطاقمار فضاء
يمثلان المملكه العربيه السعوديه واظهرت
لقطه مصوره هبوطا ناجحا على الارض لقاعده
الصاروخ الذي حمل الرواد الى الفضاء واخرى
رواد الفضاء وهم يختبرون انعدام الجاذبيه
في مقصوره دراغون
نهنئ القياده ونبارك لهم نجاح الاطلاق
وارسال اول رائده فضاء سعوديه وعربيه
ومسلمه واول رائد فضاء سعودي الى محطه
الفضاء الدوليه نبارك للوطن بكل فخر
واعتزاز هذا الانجاز التاريخي في خدمه
الوطن والعلم والانسانيه وصدقا لم يكن هذا
الانجاز ليتحقق لول الدعم الكبير والتمكين
من سمو سيدي ولي العهد رئيس المجلس الاعلى
للفضاء قبل عده اسابيع التقى برواد الفضاء
واكرمهم بكلمات ملهمه ومحفزه هي وقود
الحماس والشغف لدى رواد الفضاء لما اطلعوا
الى محطه الفضاء الدوليه هذه المهمه هي
احدى برامج
رواد الفضاء في تبع الخطه السنويه تبع
الاستراتيجيه الوطنيه للفضاء في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه اليوم في رصيد المملكه
ثلاث رواد الفضاء فيصير الترتيبنا في على
مستوى الدول مجموعه العشرين التاسع ونحن
الاول على مستوى المنطقه في عهد الفضاء
الذين صعدوا الى محطه الفضاء الدوليه رواد
الفرج يقوم بعده تجارب علميه عددها 14
تجربه علميه وطبيبيه من اهمها احدى
التجارب رفع الكفاءه علاج السرطان
والامراض المزمنه بالشراكه مع مستشفى
الملك فيصل التخصصي والثاني تجربه جدا
مهمه ولاول مره تقام على محطه الفضاء
الدوليه وهي لرفع كفاءه تقنيه الاستمطار
ولها فائده الفائده الاولى لرفع تقنيات
الاستمطار على الارض ومعالجه التحديات
البيعه على الارض والثاني ايضا لدراسه
امكانيه الاستمرار على الكواكب الاخرى
وهذه التجربه وشراكه مع جامعه الملك فهد
والبترول والمعادن
وناصر
[تصفيق]
اكد وزير خارج التركي انه سيكون من الخطا
اعاله اللاجئين الى سوريا من دون تعاون مع
رئيس السوري بشار الاسد وقالت شاوي ان
العوده يجب ان تكون تحت السيطره بمشاركه
الامم المتحده ايضا ودعم المجتمع الدولي
بما في ذلك الاتحاد الاوروبي لافتا الى
انه تم الاتفاقه على وضع خارطه طريق تعدها
لجنه خاصه
يتبعها ارسال المزيد من اللاجئين السوريين
الى المنطقه الامنه
قال موقع الداون الكتروني ان خدمات تطبيق
انستجرام التابع لشركه ميته انقطعت عن
مئات الالاف من مستخدمين وان بلاغات لاكثر
من 180 الف مستخدم تحدثت عن وجود مشكلات
في الدخول الى التطبيق في ذروه انقطاع
الخدمه فيما قال شركه للتطبيق قالت ان
الخدمات عادت لمعظم المستخدمين بعد حل
مشكله فنيه يلتقي الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن ورئيس مجلس النواب
في لحظه محوريه تشهد مصارعه واشنطن
للتواصل الى حل
وسط عفوا بشان الميزانيه ورفع حد الاقتراض
في الوقت المناسب ومن المقرر ان يعقد
الاجتماع اليوم بين الرئيس الديمقراطي
والرئيس الجمهوري الجديد لمجلس النواب
حاسما في الوقت الذي يتسابق فيه رجلان
لمنع ازمه ديون تلوح في الافق
وكان الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن افاد في
وقت سابق بان المحادثات التي اجراها مع
مكارتي حول رفع سقف الدين الامريكي كانت
ايجابيه حسب قوله
تفصل الامريكيين عشره ايام عن تخلف
الخزانه الامريكيه عن دفع بعض المستحقات
الماليه وقد اكدت وزيره الخزانه الامريكيه
جوني تيلن انها ستضطر لذلك في بدايه الشهر
وتبدو الاداره الامريكيه والجمهوريون على
مسافه من الاتفاق لاسباب مبدعيه
كما قال الرئيس يجب ان يفهم الامريكيون
اننا جميعا مهتمون بمساله العجز والصرف
بمسؤوليه لكن من الممكن معالجه مساله
العجز بتعديل الانفاق وايضا بتعديلات
الدخل
في المقابل حذر رئيس مجلس النواب الامريكي
الجمهوري من ان المشكله الحقيقيه هي
استمرار الاداره الديمقراطيه في سياسه
الصرف وتحميل الاجيال المقبله مسؤوليات
الديون
مع الرئيس وقبل ان تتحدث عن موعد العجز عن
الدفع قلت له لنتحلى بالمسؤوليه ونجلس
ونفاوض ونضع امريكا على مسار مختلف ونصرف
اقل وننمي الاقتصاد وندخر حيث هدرنا
يبدو الطرفان الان وكانهما عند رغطه الصفر
واهم الخلافات يدور حول رفع نسبه الضرائب
على شركات النفط والميسوري ومدفوعات
الدوله لشركات الادويه ووضع شروط اضافيه
على المستفيدين من المساعدات الحكوميه
ومساعدتهم للعوده الى سوق العمل
وقد اضطر الرئيس الامريكي لاختصار جولته
في المحيط الهادئ والعوده الى واشنطن
لمتابعه المفاوضات مع ماكارتي لكنه ابقى
الباب مفتوحا امام استعمال التعديل
الدستوريه الرابع عشر لتخطي اعتراض
الكونجرس الامريكي
زعماء الكونغرس الاربعه اتفقوا على
الامتناع عن الدفع اكرر الامتناع عن الدفع
ليس خيارا واتوقع من كل منهم الالتزام
بهذا الوعد لا يريد الطرفان تحمل مسؤوليه
تعثر ديون الدوله الامريكيه ولديهما الان
عشره ايام للتوصل الى اتفاق وربما يكون
هذا وقتا كافيا للخروج بنتيجه ايجابيه في
الغنمه العربيه واشنطن
وزاره الحج والعمره باول دفعه حجاج وصلوا
الى مكه المكرمه ووصلت الدفعه الاولى من
الحجاج الى مطار الملك عبد العزيز بجده
قبل الذهاب الى مكه مروان في مركز استقبال
الحجاز الذي تمت فيه الاحتفاليه بحضور عدد
من مسؤولي وزاره الحج والعمره وبلغ عدد
الحجات الذين وصلوا الى مكه حتى يوم امس
اكثر من 800 حاج نتابع
[موسيقى]
هكذا استقبلت مكه المكرمه اولى طلائع
الحجاج في الاهازيج الفرائحيه وكذلك
الاستقبال
والسرور الذي امتلا في هذه الاركان
لاستقبال اولى طلائع الحجاج في عام 2020
23 حيث استقبلت مركز النواريه ولا طلائع
الحجاج عبر عشره حافلات صباحا وعشره
حافلات مساء سيكون العدد حتى المساء اليوم
دخلوا الى مكه استعدادا للحج ولو كان
مبكرا قبل شهر ونصف اكثر من 500 حاج قدموا
ووصلوا الى مكه المكرمه عبر السلسله من
الخدمات بدات من مطار الملك عبد العزيز في
جده امتدادا الى هذا المركز ودخولا الى
داخل مكه المكرمه اشاهد عدد من المسؤولين
الذين يستقبلون الحجاج مسؤولين وزاره الحج
والعمره الذي نستقبلوا الحجاج بالورود
وبالهدايا
ولعمل الضيافه لهم قبل دخولهم الى مكه
المكرمه استعدادا لاداء المناسك بعد شهر
ونصف الشهر من
[موسيقى]
نحن بنحاول قدر المستطاع انه الفتره اللي
يقضيها الحاج من اول وصوله الى المطار حتى
وصوله الى مكان سكنه ما يكون فيها اي مجال
انتصار فيكون كلها مسبقه التحضير يعني
الان الحبلتين الان استقبلناه قبل دقائق
كان جميع بيانات الحجاج كانت مرتده من قبل
48 ساعه عارفين بالضبط فين ساكنين مجرد
وصفه وصولهم حتى وقائمه الحجاج تاتي بشكل
مباشر طريقه الكترونيه
[موسيقى]
هؤلاء الحجاج قطعوا مسافه كبيره ومن اجل
هذه المسافه ومن اجل ان لا يكون هنالك
اجهاد عليهم يعمل المسؤولون في وزاره الحج
وكذلك كافه الجهات السعوديه على تسهيل
اجراءاتهم حيث قبل ان يقلعوا من بلادهم
بنغلاديش تم تسهيل اجراءاتهم عبر مبادره
الطريق الى مكه وهنا عمليه انتظارهم لا
تستغرق وقتا طويلا حتى يدخل الى داخل مكه
المكرمه استعدادا للقيام بالعمره وكذلك
الحج قبل شهر كامل منه على ان تتوالى
عمليات الاستقبال خلال الايام القادمه مع
وصول اول طلائع الحجاج عبد المحسن الحربي
العربيه مكه المكرمه
تعاني اكثر من يصيب حياه العالم موجه جفاف
كبيره من شانها تهدد صحه الانسان وتؤثر
ايضا على وجود بعض النباتات بحسب مجله
ساينس العلميه
قوارب غارقه وسفن حربيه قديمه وبقايا
بشريه كلها بدات منذ سنوات تظهر في مياه
بحيره ميد الامريكيه
تلك البحيرات التي تتشكل خلف سد هوفر
الشهير بين ولايتين فادا واريزونا وتعد
خزانا حيويا للبلاد انه زمن الجفاف 17
ضعفا لهذا الخزان هو حجم المياه التي جفت
في العالم
مجله ساينس القت الضوء على اكبر كارثه
مائيه يعيشها الكوكب
اكثر من 50% من بحيرات العالم تقلصت
مساحتها بفعل الجفاف خلال العقود ثلاثه
الماضيه وذلك امتدادا من بحر قزوين بين
اوروبا واسيا الى بحيره تيكيكاكا في
امريكا الجنوبيه بحسب مجله ساينس العلميه
تزايد درجات الحراره له النصيب الاكبر من
اسباب تفاقم الظاهره
فمع الاحتباس الحراري هناك ايضا الاستهلاك
البشري وبناء السدود وتراجع معدلات
الامطار بين الاسباب خلف الظاهره المطلقه
صور تقلص المساحات المائيه تحبس الانفاس
25% من سكان العالم يعيشون في مناطق تعاني
بحيراتها من الجفاف او تتبخر المياه في
سدودها ولكن كالعاده الفقراء هم الاكثر
تضررا ودول الناميه هي الاضعف جهزيه
لمواجهه الاثار المدمره مياه تفقد
صلاحيتها للشرب انواع النباتيه وحيوانيه
تختفي والصحه المهدده لدى البشر هكذا
يواجه الانسان زمن الجفاف ذلك الانسان
الذي عايش العصور الجليديه وها هو يواجه
زمن التغير المناخي وحديه المتناقضين
غرقوا الارض
وجفاف المياه
وفي ختام احد يا مشاهدينا نذكر بابراز
العناوين
الجيش الاوكراني يعلن عن هجوم الروسي
لاستهدف مدينه دينيه برو بسته عشر صاروخا
وعشرين مسيره
وزراء خارجيه دول الاتحاد الاوروبي
يجتمعون في بروكسل وحزمه عقوبات جديده
مرتخبه ضد روسيا
قوات اسرائيليه تقطيع مخيم بلاطه
بالجرافات وتقتل ثلاثه فلسطينيين والسلطه
تصفها بالمجزره
الفرقاء الليبيون يجتمعون في مدينه
بوزنيقه المغربيه للتوافق على قانون
الانتخابات
في امان الله مشاهدينا
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات